[Music]
with the Sprouse done and ready to serve
my ultimate Christmas dinner
[Music]
the turkeys cooked and rested take the
turmeric and chili roast potatoes from
the oven now they look and smell
fantastic slice the pork apricot musashi
of stuffing
[Music]
as the gravy reheats crush the warners
there's a really nice combination crush
fooled us with a turkey gravy sprinkle
in the gravy boat and it's ready to
serve
stuffing gravy
[Music]
here's the turkey
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations on your tire trapeze
fall amazing converts AC jack you have
now won Michigan time
[Music]
nice
[Music]
Merry Christmas
[Applause]
[Music]
next time on my ultimate Christmas my
favorite recipe for an alternative
Christmas dinner we've won a really nice
change to roast turkey this has her the
ultimate from the table my secret for
getting the kids involved making a
fantastic silky smooth pumpkin soup with
wild mushrooms come on Holly and my
favorite Christmas treat a gloriously
aromatic honey glazed ham roasted yet it
looks amazing
stunning food that looks and tastes
amazing but won't leave you stress